[Music]
hello hello am i on
yep cool no hey there we go i'm on
welcome welcome to the table my name is
karen miner so good to see your faces
this sunday happy pride month
yay
it was so good to see a lot of you out
last night at the pride festival in
dallas um
and we'll be back there next year so if
you missed yesterday we'll do it again
next year and hope to see the rest of
you there
um i've got quite a few announcements so
that's why i have my phone just to make
sure i don't miss any important details
first of all our welcome to the table
class that got rescheduled from last
time is happening tonight
about 15 minutes after the end of the
service
this is for anybody who wants to be a
member or if you're just interested in
learning more about the table you are
welcome to attend even if you're just
now finding out that we're doing that
class tonight we'll let you come so join
us if you'd like
uh
next
this is the first sunday of june
and every first sunday we do a meal
together and you're invited so
yay i know we have a lot of good things
happening tonight um so it's good that
you're here um we are going to do our
meal immediately after the service at
hat creek burger company in saxi it's
just a short drive up the road um is
dawn in here
i think dawn is still out there but
there's dawn
hey
say hi to dawn
a jumping bean oh and a
round of applause uh dawn's gonna be our
host at hat creek so he will jet over
there immediately after the service so
you can look for him he'll have some
table save for us and we usually try to
all sit together um
yes
and the kids really look forward to it
it's a fun time for the kids as well all
right
father's day is coming up on june 19th
and we're going to do child dedications
so if you have a baby or a child that
you would like to dedicate which
basically means you're committing as a
parent or as parents we're committing as
your church family just to help raise
the kids together because it takes a
village and to do so centered on jesus
we like to do that formally just to
remind you as a parent or as parents
that we're here for you we're all here
for each other so we're going to do that
on father's day it's a great time to do
that if you're interested
you can fill out one of the cards that
is right out the door next to the box
with your information put it in the box
or you can let brett know or myself know
if you're watching online and you'd like
to do that just leave a comment or
message us sound good
so those are our announcements
also
we didn't want to
let this time pass together without
acknowledging the shooting that happened
in uvalde as well as the many shootings
that have unfortunately happened
recently
it's been heavy on my heart i know it's
been heavy on a lot of your hearts as
well
and
we just want to just take some time it's
important to not
act like everything is back to normal
because it's not these shootings are not
normal they never will be
um they're terrible they're
heartbreaking and it's one of those
things where
even if it's not directly happening to
us it impacts all of us it impacts our
nation
and as a church we want to acknowledge
that we want to prayerfully consider how
we can not just pray about it but act
and be a part of making some good change
in this area so
the first step is praying like i know a
lot of people say thoughts and prayers
and they say well no policy and change
it does start with prayers though and
praying and through that prayer god
gives us wisdom and the holy spirit
gives us direction for what to do with
our feet and our hands and our mouths
and our finances so
what i thought we should do tonight to
mark this is to enter into community
prayer together
do that as a church family and not just
for the uvalde shooting
the buffalo shooting i mean there's just
been so many as well as
with it being pride month it's also i
also want to acknowledge that there is
still violence that happens towards
lgbtq people
and so let's lift all of this up in
prayer and be a prayerful people and
from there move into
action so if you could all rise to your
feet
we're gonna have the words up on the
screen
and so
let's pray this together
lord
make us instruments of your peace
where there is hatred
let us sow love
where there is injury
pardon
where there is doubt
faith
where there is despair
hope
where there is darkness
light
where there is sadness
joy
o divine master
grant that we may not so much seek to be
consoled as to console
to be understood
as to understand
to be loved
as to love
[Music]
for it is in giving that we receive
it is in pardoning that we are pardoned
it is in dying that we are born to
eternal life
amen
let's worship together
[Music]
there's a
and grace i look at the space between
where i used to be
[Music]
should i ever need
there
[Music]
is another
i'm no longer
[Music]
and should i fall in the space between
the remains of me
and this remedy
[Music]
standing next to me
set me free
there is a cry that holds
[Music]
in the
is
[Music]
between us nothing stands between us
[Applause]
[Music]
but the name that
is who will be through it at all
so come away in the space between all
the things
[Music]
standing next to me
to be another in the waters
holding back the seas
should i ever need
reminding
how could you bear to me
i'll count the joy come every battle
cause i know that's where you'll be
i can see the light
in the darkness as the darkness
as the prison was
[Music]
standing next to me
to be another
in the waters
holding back the seas
should i ever need reminding
how good you've been to me
count the joy come every battle
cause i know that's where you'll be
i'll
[Music]
thank you for standing on the side of
the oppressed god
for being with us in our pain
we love you
you kids are dismissed and can go to
your classrooms
and for the rest of us would you guys
join us in our prayer of the people
and whatever it is that you may be
carrying with you into this space
tonight
someone that you are burdened for or a
situation maybe these shootings um
whatever it is that you bring with you
god is with us and he is here and we are
together in this space and can hold each
other up
and hold these burdens up together
before him so that's what this time is
for please join us and
read this prayer out loud with me
for the city of saxi texas and for every
city and community and all those who
live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and will to conserve
it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and the sick
for the widow and the orphan
for the injured and suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and for all
who remember and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us so we lift these names and
situations up to you
chelsea
cancer treatments
please pray for nancy's health
please lift up those struggling with
anxiety today
for healing
for israel lewis and his body
pray for rest and strength to our
educators
for the people of evaldi
for the names and moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we've
kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light
healing and hope
peace
and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
i know there's gonna be some brighter
days
i swear that love will find
[Music]
i know there's gonna be some
days
i know there's gonna be some brighter
[Music]
oh
i know there's gonna be some brighter
days
[Music]
i know there's gonna be some brighter
days
[Music]
know
if your screams don't make a sound
oh
[Music]
in your
i is there's gonna be some brighter days
[Music]
is
i know there's gonna be some brighter
days
i know there's gonna be some bad
day
mindy is making me talk right now
i was gonna try to skip it but
um no as i was reflecting on this song
this morning you know this is a song
some of you may not know it but
having led worship i've led this song a
lot in my life to almost to the point i
could probably memorize it um
but
you know it was hitting me differently
this morning you know i was thinking
about
this declaration of saying you are good
you are good to god and how
like when i was a child
i was remarkably optimistic i had no
problem thinking that the future was
going to be brighter than what i was
standing in at that moment
and you know as i got older
more and more life happened i got more
and more disappointed by things people
let me down i just felt myself getting
colder and colder and more jaded and
more jaded until these last like
eight or nine months i just found myself
completely hard and like
questioning if god is actually good
because you know how i measured god's
goodness for the longest time was
you know success status financial
security if i had those things in my
life then god is being extra good to me
right
well
all those things kind of started to
leave me and i was like oh no god is
good my life is crashing down and i just
don't know if god is good and this
morning when i was listening to this
song it started to hit me that
these two words kept coming to my my
mind of deeper and beyond and it's it
started to hit me that god's goodness
goes deeper and beyond my financial
security that god's goodness goes deeper
and beyond
my status or my career
god's
goodness goes deeper and beyond my
ability to look like i have it all
together yeah
god's goodness goes deeper and beyond my
deep sense of failure as a father
as a husband as as a son as this guy as
a pastor you know i
it just goes deeper
and beyond yeah
and so i don't know if any of you have
had these struggles of being able to
call god good especially right now in
our culture witnessing everything
uh we're witnessing and many of you even
during pride month i can only imagine
the hate that you have felt um
but god's goodness
is so much higher and
deeper and beyond than we can even
understand and so i feel like today i
can declare this and believe it because
his goodness is different than the
goodness that i see his goodness is is
completely beyond and more beautiful and
more more amazing and
incredible than i could ever imagine
and so as we begin this song
realize that god's goodness
is better than the goodness that you can
think of
[Music]
y'all sing it with
me of my heart be the mountain where i
run
that i drink from
[Music]
you're
let the king of my heart
[Music]
is
oh
[Music]
never
me
[Music]
dead
you're never gonna let me
[Music]
oh
you are good
you're good
[Music]
oh
you are good
you're good
[Music]
and when the night
his whole
ding on
to me
god is
holding high
when the night
is
holding on
to me
god
is holding
can we just sing that as a prayer of our
lives
when the night
is
holding on
to me
god is holding
on
when the night is
holding on
to me
god
is
holding us
scott thank you that you never let us go
they were always in your hands
always in your care
when things are spinning out of control
when we're uncertain and unsure
of what tomorrow holds even what today
holds god
even if we're doing it right if we're
getting it right
in all of those moments god you are with
us
you are carrying us
you are walking this journey with us
god would we trust you
would you would you bring us through to
the other side
whatever it is that we're up against
whatever it is that we're facing right
now
god we trust you to see us through
to continue to do your good work
to continue to be the author and the
perfecter of our faith
you are a good god
you are emmanuel
god with us
god who is close
when we fly on the highest heights when
we make our bed in the depths you are
there
how do we hold on to that promise
thank you for who you are thank you for
putting people around us who can hold us
up
[Music]
who can stand with us in the fire
who can hold back the seas god we need
each other
and we need you we need our savior
we love you jesus
we ask that you be with us through the
rest of this night and this week
in jesus name
amen
thank you guys for worshiping with us
together can y'all take a seat and as
you do turn and greet the people around
you make them feel welcome and brett
will get us started on our message
well good evening
grace and peace
it is so good to be with you and um
it's a beautiful worship set beautiful
thank you team and uh it's just such a
privilege to
i don't know just to be together and to
enter god's presence you know that's
there's something really special about
that and
uh many of you know we weren't here last
week and so that was a nice little break
but i'm uh i'm glad glad to be back glad
to be with all of you
so
uh we are
uh and oh and i also want to mention
i'll give a welcome uh to those join us
online don't want to forget love you
lots
and uh also those of you who are new and
and with us anyone visiting for the
first few months we won't make you like
stand up or like come forward hi my name
is none of that none of that but um
we're just really glad that you're here
so we are in um a series we're actually
wrapping it up tonight first peter part
three now we're not done with the book
uh itself
so we're coming back in a few months
some of you maybe are a little excited
some of you are like oh my gosh the
series that never ends it doesn't first
speed or part three is ending that comes
to an end and then we'll start part four
uh later
maybe then we'll do um the book of
second peter
that was oh that told me everything i
need to know okay
not a lot of passion for that um
so anyway the uh the title of my message
tonight is a fiery ordeal a fiery ordeal
and uh our passage is first peter
chapter four uh verses 12 through 16
which says this dear friends
do not be surprised at the fiery ordeal
that has come on you to test you
as though something strange were
happening to you
but rejoice
in as much as you participate in the
sufferings of christ so that you may be
overjoyed when his glory is revealed
if you are insulted because the name of
christ you are blessed for the spirit
and of glo of glory and of god rests on
you and if you suffer it should not be
as a murderer or thief or any other kind
of criminal or even as a meddler
not totally sure what a meddler is
someone who meddles on who meddles
apparently it's not as bad as a murderer
or a thief or whatever
in verse 16 however
if you suffer as a christian
do not be ashamed but praise god that
you bear that name so i want to um kind
of start off tonight by looking a little
more closely at verse 12 and
specifically there's a line there um
to test you so verse 12 says dear
friends do not be surprised at the fiery
ordeal
that has come on you to
test you
to test you
and um i'm hearing some feedback do i
need to switch are we okay
okay
cool
um
so
all right to test you so there's this uh
there's this interesting uh little
phrase we have like in western culture
um
the it's the phrases the straw that
broke the camel's back
you all heard you all heard this one
yeah um the straw that broke i think
it's a that's a great metaphor i love
this metaphor because i'm getting this
you know sort of image of course it's
one of those rich metaphors that
eventually or immediately you kind of
see something you know and uh
i'm kind of envisioning you know this
camel which i guess in the ancient world
was like the 18-wheeler of the desert
you know
so there's this camel all uh all loaded
down all just you know bird just having
all these burdens you know oh it's
getting worse
can i go ahead and just switch my friend
is that okay let me just switch
always have a backup
all right
all right cool there we go
um
so okay so the camel so uh i'm getting
near this image of a camel and uh i'm
imagining sort of a somewhat uh you know
not a good owner like someone who just
keeps burdening this camera you know
just laying on just maybe i guess
apparently it's carrying straw you know
bales of hay or something they're
loading up load and suddenly the camel's
knees are kind of like oh it's quaking
uh oh the knees are shaking and suddenly
the owner places just one just like one
little more piece just like
dick
and that's it
that that right there that ounce that
gram that was the one
and just
i mean just crumbles now i think in many
ways um
we are that camel
and i think we can have a little bit of
compassion for ourselves because um you
know what i think this shows is kind of
um
this this truth
which is that it's often less about what
is like literally happening to us in
other words of the straw
it's more about our capacity at the
moment to handle it
you know it's like how many pieces of
straw are you already
carrying that's the thing right and
that's the thing with stress because i
think what what i love about this is it
helps us not be quite as judgy you know
what i mean because it's like we see
piece of character i could i could carry
that
i could handle that you know we see
someone in their life and they're like
just they're struggling right the stress
for them is rising it's like they're
they're for them it's the straw that
they're back right and we're like well
it's not even that much but it's not
about that thing right it's it's about
um
what kind of head space
are you in when the suffering comes you
know what kind of heart space are you in
when the suffering comes like that's in
essence like that's the test
that's the test
and just to be clear i don't think this
this verse is naming um like that god
god is gonna test you god is gonna bring
all the suffering and he's gonna pour
you know he's like the bad uh owner of
the camel you know just pouring on the
straw and just like let's see let's see
how much they can handle you know i
don't think that's what peter's getting
i think instead peter has a very you
know
new testament view of the world which is
yes god is in some sense like um
sovereign overall right god is
transcendent and overall and yet um the
world itself um
you know the fall has happened the it's
gone crazy
right this this place this cosmos is in
some sense under the sway of the
principalities and the powers and bad
things happen evil things happen things
that are not the will of god right and
in essence you can say god has allowed
it but not like willed it like yes pile
on that straw pile on that stress
right no that's i don't think that's
what so i don't think that's what
peter's name mean is god's gonna test
you and i just think he's naming like
the the stress will come
the stress will come the testing we live
in a crazy world the testing will
come
[Music]
the question kind of is going into it
what kind of head space are you and what
kind of a heart space are you in how
cause that's gonna like
be about your capacity
um there's a reminds me of a story my
one of my professors told
i don't think he was the young man but i
think he had like heard about this but
there was a young man who was a
therapist therapist in training
and some of his um
clients were at a local prison
and um these prisoners in particular
they were they had very violent
backgrounds um
and so he was there to you know do some
therapy with him be there for him
and he had a like more senior um
therapist there as well kind of you know
coaching him overseeing him
so he he goes in um starts doing some
counseling and honestly it just wasn't
what he expected you know and talking
with these folks he had like a certain
expectation in his mind of like how they
would be
and he thought um
he thought he'd be able to sense
the fury
just beneath the surface you know like
maybe sense the anger the
the ray you know like
uh it wasn't there
they're just they're normal just like
super chill just like uh processing
things talking you know what else
and he was just completely flabbergasted
like
so he went to the more seasoned
therapist and he asked about this like
honestly i'm a little thrown off now
what he expected her to say was well
that's just because you're judgey you
know you went in there with certain
expectations of oh they're this kind of
person you know and you're wrong but
that's not what she said
instead what she said was um well that's
because
you haven't seen them under stress
that that's
where their ugly side comes out
and honestly
that she said is where all
of our ugly sides come out
that story has never left me because i i
think what it names is
like
what i really want the test to be
it's like when i'm on vacation
you know like like to use the language
of peter you know the
the test of say my christian faith my
whatever exact phrase you want to use my
discipleship to jesus my commitment to
follow christ to love god and love
people you know whatever like i want
that test to be issued while i'm on
vacation i'm like well rested you know
or maybe here at church you know like
this is the test here we're here and how
well do we love each other and love god
and like great all right we are passing
you know like because the truth is the
problem is that here like well you know
i mean um
we're on so to speak you know it's very
social pub public thing now hopefully
we're not just like being complete
phonies and
you know um but still
there's a social element here and you
know
um
so this isn't the test you know the
what's the test the test
the test is who am i
like behind closed doors who am i
like to the people closest to me you
know the people the people often maybe
that you live with
you know that you can't like often isn't
it interesting that those the folks we
struggle the hardest like the most to
love
isn't that fascinating like these are
the people we love the most and it's so
darn hard
and why because
because we're not just with them on
vacation
you know we're with them in the hard
times we're with them when the stress is
rising when we've like taken it like
just day after day after day and a thing
has happened and then another thing and
then another thing and another thing and
the straw it just keeps getting piled on
and we're getting burdened down and like
they see us
they see us and and the question is
in that moment
like who are we
who are we no i don't ask that to shame
you know because the truth is we're all
um to use the metaphor you know ugly so
to speak we're all not um it's not good
we'll put it that way it's not good
but like
how bad is it
you know and that like in many ways i
think that's actually the litmus test
of our
faith
you know because it's easy to come here
and be like i love god i love god praise
jesus
you know i mean frey i don't know maybe
probably no one actually says it like
that but
i love god
jesse who does our audio don't edit that
out and then put it on facebook you know
i love god
um
yeah um
but in essence yeah but that's the
moment you know
like that's that's the thing
um
because you know let's be like really
clear just to commit to follow jesus um
doesn't mean that we like get an
exemption from the test you know from
the suffering from the i know like and
we know that intellectually i see some
nodding like yes we know that like
and yet don't we kind of hope that's the
case you know i mean like the day we get
baptized it's like god's gonna kind of
rewrite the story you know like okay
okay they don't have to like go through
all that you know or something like um
we kind of i think there's a part of us
where we're sort of holding on like yeah
but
but maybe but maybe you know
um but
no dear ones
it doesn't work like that does it and i
think this is why
um peter used this language he says dear
friends um do not be surprised
do not be surprised at the fiery ordeal
that has come on you to test you as
though something strange were happening
um
but that's that's just the thing we we
are surprised aren't we i'm sure i am
surprised every time
just to be real like i'm like every time
i'm like
what no i don't deserve this i am trying
so hard you know
uh we are surprised
every time
i uh i think
one one little collective scenario
suffering we've obviously all been
through that's sort of helpful because
like relatable you know is uh the
pandemic you know covet
it's like a season of collective
suffering you know
and um
for me
it was it was interesting timing because
we launched the table four months before
that
and um
me and god we had words
you know
we had some more because
well here i uh here i am it's all me you
know here i am god like what about the
team brett okay well i've yeah
here we are
serving the lord
you know
and then all this hits and like and
honestly for me it wasn't just like some
mild anxiety you know like i was just
straight up afraid like oh my gosh we're
gonna die you know like this we get
because you know um
heard i remember who said that someone
said beginnings are vulnerable things
that's a good line
and
you know i knew we were beginning
and i just felt like oh my gosh it's too
too soon i'm not gonna you know i just
um
i was just i mean honestly i was just
straight up like afraid
you know
i was
surprised
i was shocked at the fiery ordeal that
had to come
upon us and maybe you know everyone's
story is different it probably that
fiery ordeal probably came upon you in
your own ways
and we are we're surprised every time
and you know the key word there too is
and we are um
we are
afraid
fear i think the the surprise at the
fiery ordeal that kind of gives you an
image right someone who's surprised at
the fiery ordeal that's not you know
bold and confident you know that's a
picture of
you know
fear
and um and that was me
um afraid
afraid i think this is what he captures
so well with his language not only of
surprise but also that phrase as though
something strange were happening to us
you know that's the image just like what
is this we're like it's unknown it's big
it's scary it's stressful it's difficult
stress is rising and with it the fear is
rising
um another way we might put it
is that our suffering often comes less
from the actual pain of the situation
we're enduring than the stories we tell
ourselves about the pain
isn't that interesting like you would
think the the terrible thing would be
the actual thing
and that's sure that can be quite
terrible but honestly you know honestly
when there's like a situation we tend to
kind of deal with it you know like
either we accept it or if we can change
it we change it we just like act you
know but what the worst thing is when
it's like there
and we don't really like accept it or
change we just kind of you know
think on it
i'm thinking of um for example like when
someone does a kind of a heroic thing
like i don't know they they go into the
burning building to save their neighbor
you know they um they say there's the
child drowning in the raging river and
they jump in you know and um if you ask
them afterwards like what oh my gosh you
were so brave what were you thinking
like what will they often say like uh i
honestly i wasn't
i just kind of found my body responding
you know like oh my that must have been
so difficult
i don't know
not really
it just before i knew what happened i
was in the water you know what i mean
and in essence what's strange about that
is we would think well they're terrified
because it's tremendous suffering i mean
not just a metaphorical fiery ordeal
that's like an actual burning building
that's like actual death by drowning
that must be terrible but it wasn't so
terrible why because it was just a
situation that you deal with
the hard part
is up here like if we told him one week
from now you're gonna have to go to
burning building and save your neighbor
that would be the true suffering you
know i mean we might even draw a little
bit of a distinction between like pain
and suffering you know i mean like the
pain is like the ordeal the thing the
difficulty the situation that you know i
mean
the suffering
oh god
it's it's the it's the storyline usually
negative i mean it's rare that we're
like
tell stories of i can do all things
through christ who strengthens me you
know
it's uh we try you know but usually it's
the negative storylines it's the fears
it's the thoughts you know run and run
and run and run and run and run and run
honestly it happens some of us like for
some of us don't even realize it's
happening in fact most of times like few
days will go by and then we realize oh
wow yeah i've been doing this for quite
some time old i've woven a whole story
line about my life and
you know
um
so i think
kind of what we have to come back to is
a sense of acceptance
you know like if we if we can't change
it i mean by all means if you can do
something to change your suffering like
i don't think god's like well no no this
is super good for you so continue you
know i think no no if like if you can
change it wouldn't change it but if not
what then
i think there's a level
of learning to accept
accept accept not not that it's like oh
this is awesome that's not what i mean
but accept that it
is
it is
i'm in a fiery ordeal
it is happening and i'm kind of hurting
right now
all right that's even different than the
whole storyline about why and how god's
rejected me and this always happens to
me and you know i mean like we
it's it's sort of just a simple oh god
here i am
help me to accept
help me to accept it
you know i love this metaphor of i don't
love it but it's a good one of fire
fiery ordeal you know because fire yes
it burns it hurts but also what else
does fire do fire
purifies
fire warms fire transforms
and sometimes it's actually in the very
act of receiving it
and saying okay
here we are
here's my fiery ordeal i
accept it god
and i trust
that you're with me in the midst of it
like that in and of itself can be
extremely transformative
powerful a turning point honestly in
people's lives there's a brene brown
quote
she says this when we're suffering
many of us are better at causing pain
than feeling it
we spread hurt
rather than let it inside
so that's the downside to not accepting
it we sort of live in somewhat of denial
and then
we kind of act out from it we don't
realize that's what we're doing but
that's sort of what we're living from it
you know instead of accepting it and
then
working through it
another way we might put it is that our
pain from suffering often comes less
from the actual thing we're enduring
than our destructive avoidance
of it
you know it's it's often the avoiding of
pain
is like where we go wrong fact you can
often think of addiction
as this
pain avoidance
fiery ordeal avoidance like i don't want
to feel that
i don't want to receive that i don't um
so i'm gonna you know we all have our
drug of choice
don't we i mean it's easy to kind of be
in a certain judginess of people who are
really into the hard drugs or something
you know but the truth is we're sort of
all addicts in our own ways we all have
our ways of avoiding
but i think that's sort of the
invitation from god is like okay
we can do this
you know and i'm not putting this on you
like i'm right there with you like we
guys we can do this we can face our
fiery ordeals
we we can trust that god is with us we
can accept it and then start to move
through it and here's what's here's
what's beautiful
um is if we're to trust the scriptures
and i think we should
um
seems like a good idea
what can actually happen is as we move
to that place of acceptance
we just might find that yes as many was
singing earlier in the whole team that
that the darkness is holding on to us
that's true it lingers right i wish you
could be like if you accept it'll just
be poof gone not necessarily
right so the darkness holds on
and yet what might we find god is
meeting us in the midst of it god is
holding on to us too god is holding on
to you too god is meeting you right
there in the midst of your muck in mire
god sees you god loves you god is
present to you because i think what
happens like when we're avoiding we're
kind of living in unreality
you know it's sort of like someone in
deep denial it's like well they're just
not even here
you know i mean like do you even know
what's going on
in yourself or in the world or you know
it just did not and i think in a similar
way god like
in some sense is always present to us
right there's nowhere we can go where
god is not but like in a deeper level
and a sense of feeling the connectedness
we don't feel it when we're in unreality
you know but the minute we like slow
down and say okay
okay god
here i am hurting
this sucks
would you meet me
something beautiful can start to happen
i want to close with this story this is
from acts chapter 16.
it's the uh
the a story
um
of of men paul and silas who were on a
pretty incredible missionary journey
and
um they had this remarkable experience
where uh they were traveling around it
was through the city of philippi
uh and
they were preaching there
and this uh there's a woman who was um
the bible says she was demon-possessed
and she was disrupting their preaching
and she kept yelling out
um this as they're trying to preach and
then she's at the back and she's yelling
out these men are servants of the most
high god telling you how to be saved
so she kept feeling
over and over not just for hours the
bible says she yelled this for days
these men are servants of the most high
god telling you how to be saved like
it's weird because she's selling she's
speaking the truth but she's weirdly
disrupting that you know finally the
apostle paul he got just sick of it and
he says in the name of jesus come out of
her
and the evil spirit just leaves
now this may sound like a happy story um
and up to that point it is
until
um
some men
had been making money off her because
this evil spirit had given her some
ability to kind of discern things about
people um and even about kind of their
future so it's like a fortune telling
scheme so they were using her to make
money
and so suddenly their you know little
money-making machine is like
the game's up
and they are furious
they had some influence in that city so
they went to the leaders then they went
to the people and they got a mob of
people going
and they that mob went and attacked paul
and silas the bible says that they were
stripped naked they were beaten with
wooden rods
they were then thrown into prison
and chains were placed around their
ankles
i mean i'm imagining that moment if
you're them
like
there you are trying to do good
trying to set people free trying to tell
others about jesus
and this is what you get back like god
where are you don't you care don't i
mean
i can't imagine
that kind of moment
but then we come to this beautiful line
this is from verse 25 of acts chapter
16.
it says this about midnight
paul and silas were praying
and singing hymns to god
and the other prisoners
were listening to them
isn't that beautiful there they are
praying and singing hymns
to god it reminds me of someone we
talked about a few months ago if you
remember fannie lou hamer the civil
rights activist who also
went beaten
falsely imprisoned
looked to her partner and they began to
sing
hymns to god
what's why
i think there's something about prayer
that is the opposite of fear
and there's something about worship
that is the opposite of our stories of
rejection
and aloneness
see this is the truth
god
is
with you
no matter what fiery ordeal you find
yourself in today this week this month
this year god is with you you are not
alone
i think this is why peter says in verses
13 and 14 there's some really weird
words he says but rejoice
that's a weird word isn't it in the
context of all the verses rejoice
as inasmuch as you participate in the
sufferings of christ so that you may be
overjoyed
when his glory is revealed
and when is his glory revealed i think
one way to read that would be like at
the second coming you know it's terrible
now but later there'll be real glory you
know um i i think actually his glory can
be revealed in you right now
right in the midst of it as we accept
the fiery ordeal
and then turn to god in prayer and
worship verse 14 if you are insulted
because the name of christ you are
blessed you're blessed you're blessed
for the spirit of glory and of god rests
on
you
and so as we come to the table tonight
um
i'm reminded that another word for
communion we call communion but some
traditions call it um eucharist
and eucharist
means
thanksgiving thanksgiving and so as we
come to the table
i want it to be a moment where
where we bring our full selves including
our fiery ordeal
you know where we bring ourselves but we
do it in a posture of thanksgiving not
in a weird way of like i just love this
you know but but in a way of
thanksgiving that
the christ whose body was broken the
christ whose blood was poured out
um
is with us
is for us
is deeply connected to us and we're not
alone
we're not alone so so in a moment as you
come forward that's the the heart
posture um that i'd like you to come
forward with tonight
so um instructions for how to take
communion are going to be on the screen
and we practice what's called an open
table meaning if you're here tonight and
you want to participate
then you just feel free come on forward
so this is the table
not of the church
but of the lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love
him more
so come
come you who have much faith in you who
have little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow and you who
have failed
come
because it's the lord himself who
invites you
and it's his will
that those who want to meet him
should meet him here
come to the table
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
do
if you guys want to stand with us we are
going to close out with
um a hymn
that you probably have heard before
if you were around church at any point
in your life growing up
the lyrics of this song
karen is actually the one that brought
it up to me this week but with brett's
message just talking about um
suffering and trials and how do we come
through the other side where is god in
the midst of that
it has those familiar words it is well
it is well with my soul and
as we were talking just a minute ago
about allowing ourselves to feel pain
instead of avoiding it and running the
other direction
um
i have found myself this week asking
like
am i am i am i able to sit in it am i
able to really be there
and
and listen to jesus and hear
what he's speaking to me in this moment
when what i really want to do is
take control and do things my way
and work them to
my comfort
i would really like to be comfortable
and i would really like to have it all
right that is my preferred way of
operating
and instead i just
hear god asking me can you sit in this
can you can you feel it with me
can you open up your hands
can you trust me
and when we were rehearsing this earlier
i just had i was choking back tears just
because
that question feels very real right now
and to be able to say
it is well whatever you're bringing my
way
it's gonna be okay i'm gonna trust you
in this you're gonna see us through
you're going to
guide us where we are uncertain where
there is darkness where there is
you know
lots of insecurity
and fear
i'm going to say
that's okay
it's well with my soul
it's well with my soul so you guys sing
this with us
and um i just invite you to open
yourself up
sit with whatever it is that's on your
heart whatever pain let's sit in that
with jesus and see what he might be
speaking to us what he might be saying
to us
in that situation
[Music]
when peace
whatever
[Music]
it is
is
[Music]
in the lord
hates the day
when my
faith
shall be
signed
[Music]
scroll
shall descend
[Music]
even
so
it
is well
with
my soul
[Music]
is
souls
[Music]
indeed
with
my soul
[Music]
with
my soul
it
is
[Music]
it is
[Applause]
is
[Music]
the service met you right where you are
and blessed your soul
um
don't forget
we have the welcome to the table class
for those that are attending that
uh and then for those of you who are not
attending the class uh please go to hat
creek burger company we're meeting there
for dinner in a little while
um
also if you are visiting with us tonight
we would love to have you fill out our
visitor card it's right outside the door
and to your right just drop it in the
box your name and contact information
we'd love a chance to connect with you
and then lastly
if you could stand your feet
i would like to send you out into your
week with a benediction that
i believe is true for each and every one
of you in here
and each one of you who are watching
online
and especially for those of you that
have
either now or in the past struggled with
shame
with guilt
with feeling less than or unworthy
this is especially for you
you are a child of god
you
are a child of god
this is true on your best day
and it's especially true on your worst
day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy
and you are accepted
just as you are
and go
filled with god's holy spirit
and the desire to extend these gifts of
love
and grace
and compassion
to everyone you come in contact with
this week
be blessed we hope to see you back here
next sunday have a good night
full sail university is a place where
creative dreamers go to learn their
craft
filling the world
[Music]
so
um
[Music]
we